the federal government is hitting the
pause button tonight on what could be
one of the biggest and most
consequential technology deals ever it
involves an American company and the
administration concerned that a hostile
foreign takeover could jeopardize
American leadership in a critical
industry correspondent Julian Turner
looks at what a stake at stake rather in
that deal tonight we will stand up to
any country that unlawfully forces
American companies to transfer their
valuable technology as the worldwide
race to develop 5g the fifth generation
of wireless technology heats up a single
takeover deal is threatening to
undermine America's competitive edge in
the tech sector and jeopardize its
national security interests San
diego-based Qualcomm is currently
leading the pack when it comes to 5g
research and development but a
Singaporean company called Broadcom is
now making a bid to acquire Qualcomm for
a staggering 117 billion dollars one of
the largest deals the tech sector has
ever seen experts now warn that were the
deal to go through
Qualcomm America's leader in telecoms
would be forced out of the 5g race
handing a victory to its Chinese
competitors Americans should be
concerned that if China does this then
first of all they are going to dominate
global communications in the wireless
area but also that they will be able to
spy on Americans because 5g will connect
many devices in their homes but 5g
technology isn't just for your TV or
your phone it'll be used in the future
for self-driving cars and wireless
virtual reality the Trump
administration's Committee on foreign
investment in the United States known as
Sophia's is now intervened putting the
deal on hold for one month while it
undertakes a review saying quote any
other potential merger between Broadcom
and Qualcomm could pose a risk to the
national security of the United States
some senior lawmakers are also concerned
about the risks China has made it no
secret they have a national strategy
they've announced it they're
implementing it too
vacuum up startup technology companies
and other companies that produce dual
use technology that has national
security implications a former national
security official who's familiar with
Qualcomm tells FOX News that should this
deal go through it effectively forfeit
the future of American 5g bill Thank You
Gillian